[Music]
that matches the city scandal which has
seen the club banned from the Champions
League for two years is arguably just
the tip of the iceberg
the truth is English and European
football is riddled with clubs breaking
the financial rules to some extent in
England at least three championship
sites are being investigated for
financial misdemeanors and in recent
years many printing family clubs and
broken the rules to attract young
players the problem is there's no
effective regulator of English football
the FI isn't it needs the big clubs to
support both the England team and the FA
Cup if it is to side financially so how
can it also regulate them both the
Premier League and the Football League
are supposed to apply a fit and proper
person test to those buying football
clubs yet both are remarkably
ineffective at doing so the Premier
League is basically 20 separate
businesses coming together to sell their
exclusive television rights
that's a cartel by any other name and
cartels need regulating as a former
chairman of the FA I think it's time for
government to intervene and establish a
powerful independent regulator for
professional football in England
you've been director-general of the BBC
chairman of the FA yeah what else you
got on think I've had done a lot of jobs
I didn't last very long again Yoga
let me explain for our viewers what
regulation in football currently exists
just so we know ii Carroll so UEFA has
what they call Financial Fair Play it
was introduced by UEFA in 2009 to
address clubs making huge losses and
spending beyond their means losses are
limited to a level set by UEFA then in
the Premier League they have a number of
financial rules in place including
requirements for clubs to pay transfer
fees salaries and tax bills on time and
they must submit accounts annually and
disclose payments may to agents and then
finally English Football League that you
mentioned Greg introduced profit and
sustainability rules for their 2011 to
12 season limiting the losses that can
be made by clubs 239 million pounds over
a three-year period if those losses are
covered by an owner so those are the
rules in place yes now but one imagines
the reason these rules are in place
it's the stifle and to stop unfair
competition so perhaps in a scenario I
presenter you can tell us how it would
work if a foreign country likes a cutter
or whether comes in to buy a club how
does an individual owner of a club like
an individual millionaire compete
against the state that has petrodollars
and can keep buying the best place that
was the aim is that fair that was the
aim of financial first fair player in
the first place it was it was introduced
to say hang on
Brahma Vicious bought Chelsea and poured
money into it and there's nothing we can
do to stop that wishful which actually
damages competition in your demand
they're also pushing marks over where
that money came from the way well as
question marks we had a lot of money
because what man the city actually did
wrong what men should see what they're
saying what they're saying makes the
city did long was that they claimed that
Ettie aid the airline was sponsoring the
club with us chunk of money maybe now it
might not because later they they would
argue it
demonstrated that the money didn't come
from a chiid it actually came from the
government the government of Abu Dhabi
so if they've been if they're being
chucked out of this European Champions
League which will be very expensive for
them because there's a lot of potential
money they can learn from their toes why
are they not going to be kicked out of
the Premier League the European clubs
operating by a more draconian set of
rules in if so why so they're gonna be
thrown out why not well that that's
going on at the moment isn't that the
Premier League gonna kick yeah no no the
Premier League are doing their own
investigation based upon this all came
out and this is this is the problem of
the whole thing we some came out via
leaked India Spiegel in Germany and if
that if that Lee get in happened none of
this would have happened
Wow can I read their statement so this
is what the club had to say
Manchester City is disappointed but not
surprised by today's announcement in
December 2018 the UEFA chief
investigator publicly previewed the
outcome and sanction he intended to be
delivered to Manchester City before any
investigation had even begun the
subsequent flawed and consistently
leaked UEFA process he oversaw has meant
that there are who was a little doubt in
the result that he would deliver simply
put this is a case initiated by UEFA
prosecuted by UEFA and judged by UEFA
well that's why I'm saying you need
that's why I would have I mean the FA is
supposed to judge it in in the you in
England right I don't think the fi has
the capability to do that but secondly
the FA needs the big clubs to supply
players for the England team and to for
them to plan I don't think they're
equipped to actually do a proper
investigation so would you be saying
this if you were still chairman of the
FA did you say similar things easier to
say now you're no longer there no I did
say some of the things that I was
chairman it wasn't particularly like
three point three billion to the
Treasury in 2016-17 if it's doing that
what does it matter where the money's
coming from decided on a set you could
have said no we're not gonna Financial
Fair Play to anyone can put any sort of
money into any sort of club and spend
fortunately the clubs chose that wasn't
the case that it's not what they wanted
to do and therefore they introduced
Financial Fair Play I mean there were
all sorts of ways around it and I
suspect mention of City are not alone in
getting around this is like a Q&A okay
so but why do we need a regularly
regulatory body they've been fined
twenty five million quid they're gonna
be banned for two years they're gonna
lose all well I'm saying the body I
think you need a regulator of English
football to stand how you do Europeans
harder but the same people who organize
competitions are also the regulator and
that doesn't make sense
so you think the real issue is that the
clubs are overspending and overstretched
anyway so there's a statement here that
says Championship clubs had pre-tax
losses of 307 million between twenty
seventeen and eighteen and that's a
record high isn't it because they're
paying the players everybody paying the
players everybody but everybody's over
but the only consensus across but what
is they all hate ages everybody hate
agents because the asian has taken vast
sums of money as well just disappears
speaking of agents I'm gonna take over
does that work not really anyway it is
time to bring this conversation to a
close
coming up after the break why the Brits
aren't doing it for the girls
[Music]